NO CLAYTON KELLER.
THE DUCKS ON THE LINE WITH N TH
PAST HAS IT.
>> S
NICE LITTLE KICKBACK PLAY.
FINDS THE
ZEGRAS-TERRY LINE.  COACH
CHALLENGING THE DEFENSEMEN. ERT
ONE WE HAVE NOT
ALEX GALCHENYUK DROPS IT.
OPPORTUNITY, TO THE FRONT. MOVE
GETS WHACKED AT THE LAST SECOND,
RUNS OUT ON REAL STAT AND THROWS
ITNCE.
DUCKS LOOK TO SET IT UP HIGH.
BACK IN.
DEREK ON.
HE'S NOT THE SAME.
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
HE WHIFFS ONCLUB.
THEY'LL ALLOW HIM TO HANG AROUND
IN BETWEEN THE PIKES IT AROUND.
ZACH, FORMER PITTSBURGH PENGUINS
TO THE FRONT. ANT.
SHEER IS AN OP JUJU
SMITH-SCHUSTER BATTLING FOR IT.
MA OH, MY.
THAT IS OUT OF THE WAY.
HE PUTS IT AROUND HIM TOO.
WHAT A SHOT.
BID FROM
A SHOT.
WE ARE SENSING IT HERE TONIGHT.
WE'LL SEE IBENCH.
HE SCORES.
CAM FOWLER, A THE
BLOCKER, A FOOT OFFCOYOTES WILL
IT OUT.
CASTLE SHOOTING AND IT'SL WITH
PLAYER IS IN CHANCE.
THEY SCORE.
THAT'S HIS SECOND OF THE NIGHT
AND IT IS 5-0
A REBOUNDYSDALE.
HE SHOOTS A STOP. IN THIS
ZONE, THE OFFENSIVE